tonight i couldn't be prouder to be a
loyal union member
a passionate climate activist and a
patriotic democrat
or as donald trump will call me in a
tweet tomorrow
a washed up horse face no talent has
been with low ratings
well with all due respect sir it takes
one to no one
julia louis-dreyfus brought the funny to
night four of the democratic national
convention on thursday
i am so grateful to be here taking a few
digs at
president donald trump an easy way to
remember
30330 is that's the year
donald trump will finally release his
tax returns
yep she went there referencing trump's
infamous
tax returns while opening the night and
encouraging people to text
vote to 30330 to learn how to vote in
their area
if we all vote there is nothing facebook
fox news and vladimir putin can do to
stop us
but first let's reaffirm the
all-american values that our party
and joe biden stand for and in another
friendly reminder to text vote to that
same number
she threw shade at trump's golf score
and straight up
called him a cheater 3-0-3-3-0 that
would be the president's golf score
if he didn't cheat okay look
i'll admit that was a little nasty but
we all know he's a cheater
and i'm proud to be a nasty
nasty woman savage right well she wasn't
done
i'm not going to lie it was a challenge
later the emmy winner took
another jab at the president referring
to his controversial photo op at st
john's episcopal church amid the black
lives matter protests
just remember joe biden goes to church
so
regularly that he doesn't even need tear
gas and a bunch of federalized troops to
help him get there
and that is what we call a dis folks
it was sublime the 59 year old actress
also opened up about her connection to
joe biden
revealing that she first met him during
her time playing fictional vice
president
selena meyer on her hit show veep and he
was
at the time well the real life vp
i was asked to be on the cover of a
magazine it was for
arrive the official onboard magazine of
amtrak
which nobody ever reads even though it's
free
and the day it came out my phone rang
and it was the vice president telling me
he loved the cover
and the whole article and that it was
one of the best issues of arrive
he had ever read joe biden not only
knows how to read
but also he reads everything
of course biden spoke too this is a
life-changing election
this will determine what america is
going to look like for a long long time
and while julia took several blatant
swings at president trump
biden was a bit more subtle and never
actually mentioned him by name
the current president has cloaked
american darkness for much too long
too much anger too much fear too much
division
here and now i give you my word
if you entrust me with the presidency i
will draw on the best of us not the
worst
i'll be an ally of the light not the
darkness
it's time for us for we the people
to come together biden's children ashley
and hunter gave a speech
too and assured voters that their dad
was the right man for the job
he's been a great father and we think
he'll be a great president
and if that wasn't cute enough biden's
granddaughters
maisie finnegan naomi and natalie spoke
too
pop told us that this election would be
totally different from
any other election ever he was worried
how it would affect his kids
and get this guys they called a family
meeting to tell their grandad to get
in the race we just knew that he had to
run
and we weren't going to take no as an
answer
at the end of the day i think we're all
very happy we had that meeting